gentlemen let's begin do we have some
kind of letter we should read i i hate
to be the school marm here but i do
think we should proceed with business
yeah we have we have a letter we have a
letter our pennies and pallers as we
call our pen pals listeners they uh they
knew that we were going to be getting to
talk to you so someone wrote us a letter
specifically for our time together i'm
going to read it ready okay here we go
hi dan and rory and conan correct order
if you ask me a short letter from
ireland to say hi best of luck on team
coco so far it's been great i noticed
recently that i have a lot of trouble
falling asleep there are nights when i
purposely stay up until 5am for live
shows in the states such as pen pals and
bingo and trivia nights with dan which i
love doing and don't plan on stopping
however
every other night the pattern is i lie
awake until four or five am and then
sleep for a few hours any tips on
falling asleep from
sarah dunn p.s
i'm from a small town in ireland i'm
going to do my best here carrick on
sewer which is just 35 minutes from
where conan's family came from conan how
do you say this dungeorvan dungarvin
dungarvan barbarian yeah yeah i'm sorry
sorry to prove i guess here i don't care
about the irish yeah dungarvan dungarvan
okay yeah so
she stays awake all night how do you
guys fall asleep are we going to pass
over that she knows this much about
conan i mean that's terrifying that's
stalker well didn't conan didn't you go
and i'm exactly 35 minutes door to door
from conan's family
rory i think it would be frightening if
i weren't such an icon
um
seriously if someone says oh abe lincoln
how's your wife mary todd you don't go
whoa stalker
it's the lincoln you know what i'm
saying and i think i'm the lincoln of
comedy i'm depressed i'm 6'4 yeah uh
some find me homely
um and uh i'm trying to unite a nation
so
i think in all those ways i'm lincoln
well a lot of comics say that they go oh
here comes abe lincoln heads up and then
and then you walk out yeah i think it's
mostly because when people see me
performing at a theater they'd like to
shoot me no i think the that's the big
that's how the whole lincoln thing got
started oh fair enough i'd like to put a
derringer bullet in the back of his head
anyway we it took a dark turn let's move
forward gentlemen um what do you think
rory do you have trouble sleeping and
what do you think we should tell sarah
dunn who lives with 35 minutes from
dungarvan
what do you think we should tell her i
you know i i i'm curious what you would
tell her but i i have trouble sleeping
as well i feel like for the past i don't
know maybe two years i
i don't know if i'm getting adequate
sleep and i don't know how to how to
know don't you before you start quit
yelling at me about these apps you're
gonna go well you gotta download it am i
sleeping app or sleep app or sleep
sleepy time app i don't i don't know
understand those and i don't know if i'm
getting enough
what's your what's your routine like
what do you what do you do you have a
system several screens in front of me
going throughout the night so that when
i wake up my emails are right there and
i can check and see if anyone's dm to me
on instagram within seconds well i think
that's the first thing we're going to
address obviously you're making some
kind of a i guess what your generation
would call a joke uh but
not all of us what i would say to sarah
dunn first of all is you've got to
eliminate all screens and i think that's
the point of rory's little i guess it's
equip i don't know what it qualifies
with his generation also my generation
is i'm i don't know what the lowest one
is but i'm 17 years old just to catch
listeners to catch up with the beard of
a confederate soldier
and apparently the diet uh
what i'd like to point out is
what i'd like to point out
is that sleep is all how you prepare for
it so
um i find yes no screens at night i i
watch
some of my classic bits
uh and i encourage my children and my
wife to watch them too so we have
i would say from like seven to nine
where 9 30 is watching conan classic
bits they've seen them before and
they're very unhappy about it but we
watch them um no but no no screens no
screens and then uh if you can
uh read i think reading do you do that
every night yeah i find if i read i
naturally get sleepy and i try to read
really boring books
really dense boring books
and uh that'll put you out i think
reading is good and they're actually
studies
sarah i'm not kidding that the eye
movement across
a uh page
as you scroll across as your eye darts
uh from left to right uh unless you're
reading the torah hello
as your eye moves from left to right and
then back again is hypnotic and puts you
into a state for sleep so reading's a
good idea i've never heard that i do
you've never heard i haven't read it
no i never heard about the eye movement
sort of being like a put you into like a
trance-like state of true story not a
yeah um i don't travel with a box fan
i'm not one of one of those but i do
need like a sound machine preferably yes
cold like if i if i can it's 68 degrees
is obviously perfect but sound machine
and like a mundane podcast of like there
used to be like a radio
overnight radio show out of chicago and
they would they would drop their show as
a podcast they would just talk about
like general pop culture and if i could
put that on it with the sound machine
and it just kind of takes away my own
thoughts and regrets of what i didn't do
today and what i need to do tomorrow i
made a mistake a bunch of years ago i
read uh that get a sound machine is a
good idea or listen to a sound machine
as you're falling asleep and i thought
they meant the miami sound machine with
gloria stefan
and so
i would listen
on very big speakers too come on
everybody
[Music]
and it wasn't working and i thought i'm
not listening to it loud enough i'm not
listening to it uh enough times so i
kept going louder and more times
you're definitely you definitely weren't
learning the lyrics no that's no no it
was more of a
of all i blame the speakers the speakers
were turns out uh very bad quality
so
it wasn't that
hard all i could hear was
don't don't bump
what you did like as much as it was bad
with the lyrics it was excellent
yes
listen i took what was probably a mildly
amusing quip and what i did is i put all
my chips on it i kept investing in it
every chip and i put not only that but i
called my business manager and had him
put my house on the line my mortgage
everything i really invested heavily in
that joke
that may have put you to sleep sarah the
fact that i went that hard that deep
into what was clearly just a stupid
reference to the miami sound machine
with gloria stefan what's your favorite
favorite besides the bible what is your
favorite book well it's hard to have a a
favorite book um
i i don't have any one favorite book i
read so many of them yeah so when you're
trying to find a boring book how do you
know what's going to be a boring oh you
can tell right away
you can tell
okay any biography let's say you want to
read a biography of a great man and
let's say that man is franklin delano
roosevelt okay if you find what i love
is when a biographer and when i say i
love it it's i hate it when instead of
just starting with franklin delano
roosevelt being born what they do is
they go back 800 years before then and
go that delano clock clan
of upper um you know amsterdam uh they
and then they take you through
17 generations before you even get to
franklin delano roosevelt that's a book
that will put me right out they'll say
he was a simple printer and then he
married this person who married that
person and i'm gone i'm completely out
so make sure it's a biography that
starts 600 years before the birth of our
hero